there was a complicated tension in old
regime society on the eve of the
Revolution it was a society caught
between two worlds on the one hand it
was structured by privileged hierarchy
custom and tradition birth and blood
should determine everyone's status
Nobles should rule over commoners
because after all they have blue blood
naturally flowing in their veins on the
other hand this is a society that's
tremendously dynamic commercial exchange
openness to new ideas growing cities new
money new goods from the colonies lots
of things were up for sale including a
system of privilege itself and many
people argued that it should be merit
not privilege of birth that determines
status now this tension between the old
world and the new world is absolutely
crucial for unlocking why the revolution
happened by the 1780s there's a real
mood of uneasiness dis consent
discontent and uncertainty even among
the elites even though many people are
clinging to the system of privilege for
their own sakes they're also questioning
it deeply to set the mood I want to tell
you about one of the most popular plays
of the 1780s it was a play that
questioned the traditional system of
hierarchy the play by Beaumarchais is
called The Marriage of Figaro it
undermined and mocked the old
aristocratic value system and like the
diamond necklace affair in the last
lecture this play will give us an
insight into the mood of critical public
opinion in the 1780s first let me
emphasize that the theatre could be a
very political space in the 18th century
the theatre was a place for playing with
ideas or even criticizing the crown
ordinary people even illiterate people
could go to plays it was cheap to get
into the pit in the standing room
section on the floor of the
ughter a Beaumarchais wrote The Marriage
of Figaro in 1778 the Royal censors
rejected it in fact it seems so radical
that the head censor showed it to the
king himself and louis xvi famously said
this shall never be played it would be
necessary to destroy the Bastille itself
before this play would be without
dangerous consequences
this man mocks at everything in the
government which should be respected so
the play was censored and banned from
public production it was read in private
salons and became secretly popular
finally in 1784 the Royal censors
decided to allow it to be performed in
one of the main theatres of Paris early
on the day of the play crowds of four to
five thousand people were already in the
courtyard of the theater lining up for
tickets when the doors opened the crowd
poured in some accounts claimed that
three people were even trampled to death
on the way in and during the performance
the audience was very moved apparently
women fainted at crucial moments The
Marriage of Figaro became one of the
smash hits of the century it broke
records it played 73 knights in its
first year it made three hundred and
fifty thousand livre within eight months
incidentally this play would become the
basis of Mozart's opera his 1786 opera
by the same name but he Cook toned down
its controversial nature
now why was Beaumarchais play so
controversial and so popular why do
people rush to see it now if you read it
now it doesn't seem so subversive
but at the time it did in the play
Figaro the servant worries that his lord
the count is plotting to seduce Figaro's
fiance Susanne the plot plays with an
old medieval tradition that noble Lords
had the right had the privilege to steal
away new peasant Brides on their wedding
nights on this first night the Lord
would replace the poor peasant groom in
the wedding bed now this no longer
happened but it still held symbolic
power Figueroa plays a feisty servant
who's constantly one upping his master
like so many other theatrical servants
before him but he also voices his anger
at the system of privilege
here's Figaro in his most powerful
soliloquy because you are a great
nobleman you think you are a great
genius nobility fortune rank position
how proud they make a man feel what have
you done to deserve such advantages
where as I lost among the obscure crowd
have had to display more knowledge more
calculation and skill merely to survive
than has suffice to rule all the
provinces of Spain for a century of
course
beaumarchais meant France when he said
Spain here his play hit on earth it was
profoundly egalitarian it was anti
hierarchical in the 1780s it joined a
whole chorus of public questioning
public criticism of immoral aristocrats
you